yeah hey what's up my name is samuel
leeds right now i'm driving
i'm on my way back from liverpool i'm
i'm inside
my like for like replacement car russell
what car we in
uh you know what this is absolutely
hilarious so
obviously as many of you will know he
drives a a big
white range rover a big white range
rover which got crashed into
while i was doing the viewing i was
going out to view a property someone
went into the back of me
and they they took my range over off me
they said don't worry
we'll give you a like for like car
russell is this like my range rover
the only way to light your range over is
in how new it is
and the fact that it's white it is a
smart car this is a smart car literally
i'm driving about
60 miles an hour on the motorway the car
is blowing me
it feels like um it feels like i'm
driving 120 miles an hour i'm going on
i'm going down 60 miles an hour so we've
just been to liverpool
um and you know what we're doing you've
probably seen i'm doing a refurb on a
property in liverpool
and here's one of the most important
things when you're doing a refurb on a
property
have the end in mind so russell who have
been who we've been visiting today so
we've been visiting hmo managers today
finding out
um it's actually very very interesting
when you go in the offices you find out
a lot about them and how much
you know what their what their values
are even yeah how much did you pay
to manage your hmo property i'd say on
average i'd say 12 percent
yeah you know 12 don't go for the
cheapest i was chatting to a guy today
and he was saying that
his hmo management um company was
charging him eight percent
but i'm thinking i don't want to pay
eight percent to have my hmos managed
i want to pay 12 because if i play 8
i know they're not going to do a good
job liverpool hmos
don't mix dss tenants with professional
tenants you need to decide who's your
market
who's in your power team get the right
management team in place
so yeah we're coming back now i'm
excited about the property investors
crash course tomorrow brother if you're
going to be on the crash course
comment below let me know also you're
going to be the property investor
specialist tomorrow
i'm i'm the everyone man if you've not
been to the property investors crash
course you need to
get there tomorrow everything has
changed in 2021
property investing is not like it was in
2020
it's definitely not like it was in 2019
so we're running the crash course
tomorrow how many hours is the crash
course
the crash course is about 12 hours about
12 hours long
we start first thing tomorrow morning
and it's free
okay it's free to attend and it's
virtual you don't even have to leave the
house
you don't have to leave the house it
will feel like you're at a physical
event though
you know i'll be on stage and stuff it's
a free course there's a one pound
booking fee
to check you're a real person but it's
free so you know what it's now friday
night
i'm heading back to buckinghamshire um
russell why don't you just show them
that you actually
look good and you're a real person not
just behind the screen
this is russell leeds all right top two
reasons why they should attend the crash
course
uh number one top two reasons the first
reason you should attend the crash
course is because
it's loads and loads of value and it's
free that
i honestly think it is the best return
on investments pounds
i can't see how you can get a better
return on investment you guys are all
investors
you want good return on investment this
is the best one you're gonna get the
first reason
oh yeah second second reason is you're
gonna you're gonna
it's not just samuel samuel's gonna be
there but you're gonna see some great
property trainers
you're gonna see i don't know man just
so much value i'll find the deal
tomorrow right
i'll literally be finding a deal
tomorrow and and here's the thing
12 years i've been in property my
knowledge
12 years condemns into one day so we're
actually
we're not just trainers we're property
investors first training second out on
the road
brussels doing deals all the time
whistles just secured a piece of land
where we're going to be building some
more houses on it which is really
exciting so if you want to be a property
investor
click the link in the description get
down to the property investors crash
course and i can't wait to get to know
unc tomorrow
final words of advice go ahead russell
final words of advice
get on the crash course take action mate
2021 your year
yeah yeah yeah you got to take action
massive action
or believe me i'll make you implement
tomorrow i'll make you get on the phone
so i'll leave a link in the description
see you tomorrow the crash course thanks
for watching
peace out see you tomorrow get